con trees los musulmanes continúan
siendo atacados con impunidad en muchos
países
nuestros santuarios están siendo
destruidos nuestro profeta mahoma es
insultado el sagrado corán quemado todo
esto en el nombre de la libertad de
expresión incidentes en europa
incluyendo la republicación de
caricaturas blasfemas en charlie hebdo
son ejemplos de ellos
señor presidente el único país del mundo
y donde lamento decir que el estado
promueve la islamofobia es india
señor presidente para desviar la
atención de sus acciones ilegales y de
las atrocidades cometidas en la ocupada
región de jammú y cachemira india está
jugando un juego peligroso aumentando la
apuesta militar contra pakistán en un
entorno nuclearizado